hey guys I'm going to be promoting my
new podcast the way back here for the
next few weeks I'm very excited it's
going to drop every Thursday beginning
January 4th right here on my YouTube
channel you don't need to subscribe
anywhere else we'll work on getting it
out there wherever you get Podcast it
will be available but you can watch
video for sure right here on YouTube yes
I'm continuing the Honeydew it's just in
addition to that something fun something
a little different um going back to my
Ro in podcasting a little bit so I'm
excited for it um it's called the way
back and it's just a Nostalgia podcast
sitting back on that that uh station
wagon back seat the one that looked out
in traffic you know that's the one the
best seat in the house talking about
growing up and you know just laughing
and having some good times you're going
to get the way back on patreon also a
day early you're going to get it ad free
as well um I'm really excited for this
show I really it got a great response
when we dropped that first teaser and uh
our first guest to kick off is Tom
sagora so it's going to be a great one
we've got a bunch of them in the can
already um you're going to see Mark
Norman Jim Gaffigan Joe list they're all
on there all right uh so make sure
you're already subscribed and uh here's
a little taste for
you I remember growing up we were
terrible kid my brother was a bit of a
pyro take GI Joe's we would tape bottle
rockets we did the mailbox baseball
we're shooting BB guns Roman Candle
fights my mom didn't like anybody she
didn't even like her own kids these are
wire neighborhoods I didn't have a
curfew or a house how's all you bro a
dog chasing us was a drag queen M noan
Ryan that fast ball boom right my
brother's
face yeah those were the
[Music]
days